forty-three seconds of logos movie opens
on almost a minute of creepy doll porn
dollhouse is coming soon how big these
doll house is gonna be Annabelle is not
Barbie sized and that was how Annabelle
was created the end David Sandberg
couldn't figure out how to open the film
so he just used old footage of Anthony
LaPaglia in an episode of without a
trace old standard being played on a
record player starts off innocent but
will soon be creepy cliched you can send
your son over tomorrow Vic they're ready
really Donnell he finished at the
beginning of the movie was one of a
hundred oh man what an asshole to be
driving like sixty past a car that's
parked in the middle of a dirt road
let that be a reminder to all you
dickweeds you're not only costing lives
you're creating Annabelle's I just wish
you in New York home instead of an yours
for this position why is it some major
revelation that Janice wears a leg brace
is the movie trying to play the sympathy
card
I guess being an orphan isn't enough
land stolen years ago for my wife hasn't
been used in ages it works fine
convenient staircase chairlift for girl
with polio that the Mullins had no way
of knowing would be part of the group of
orphans is convenient science later we
find out that Esther simply had her eye
taken out by Annabelle so was her
walking affected by that is it just me
or does it seem like her polio could
have made it up the stairs faster than
the stairway gizmo why can't those over
there okay but then where would Kate
into your niece leave orphan hierarchies
also aren't these two ultra tricks a
little too old to be orphans look this
doesn't wait - I didn't want to tell you
about this before you got a beer because
I'd much prefer to be a creepy asshole
very few people know that this was
originally a spec script about a haunted
dumbwaiter
that they turned into an Annabelle movie
it was called at your scare vez also if
the doll has this power then why waste
time with the dumbwaiter door tricks
demons this kind of horror troupe is so
tired at this point that it's an
ingredient in xanax I for one hope the
ghost daughter leaves Janice alone
she'll just start talking about drunk
driving statistics ever since she got
hit by that truck she's become so boring
thank you for bringing us all together
dad died before I wake I pray the Lord
my soul to take
I think this chapter of my blu-ray is
called to Street minutes of praying feel
free to skip man there's a middle finger
next to it tell
keep to your own business how did sister
Charlotte not know that Carol had gotten
up from the table in the first place
she's literally right next to it looks
like the Annabelle and stranger things
universe share the same lighting
manufacturers inviting parents that hate
homework Christmas video I old prayer
chatter you know what the father it made
sense to write a message that simply
says find me but when you play with
strangers maybe it's time to start
offering some clues or riddles or just
draw a map and say go here out of all
the girls be had to pick the one who can
barely walk to play her games with B
sucks
preemptive sin forgiveness is there a
forgiveness Bank of some sort says here
you've racked up a hundred preemptive
forgiveness bucks
what kind of sinning would you like to
do today lights still work on a
dollhouse that probably hasn't been
touched in 12 years yeah you're right
the dollhouse is pretty awesome it'll
make you forget a mysterious somebody
was slipping you notes telling you to go
find them and you still don't know who
it was and haven't seen them yet so go
ahead and live out your sharp objects
fantasy we don't wait strange hiding
place for the key - Annabelle's spell
and case chamber why wouldn't mr.
Mullens keep this say anywhere else also
did she hope this is what would happen
when she put notes on the ground for
Janice to follow did she think Janice
would pull up the sheet on the dollhouse
and find the key to the secret door and
furthermore is Annabelle a demon that
can wander outside of her doll body but
needs a doll body for some reason I
submit that if her ghost can do the
things we've seen her do then she could
have done the whole dish by herself just
like the first movie we never actually
see the doll move but why there have
been seven child's play films and eleven
puppet master films that show dolls and
toys moving all over the place and even
killing people there's got to be a
middle ground where it remains realistic
and scary and yet we still get to see
some Annabella oh come on
I guess that's supposed to be creepy
because the doll isn't there but what's
montt creepier is the doll actually
being there this choice just makes me
ask existential questions and I become
that unemployed philosophy major who
smells like clothes and claims he
sometimes plays bass for the features if
Annabelle was trapped in the room for
the past 12 years with all the
scriptures on the wall the crucifixes
etcetera then how did Jan unlocking the
door let her out she was clearly able to
make the door open even when Jen locked
it again so how was she ever trapped
there in the first place I think this is
where mr. Mullins keeps his wife a joke
even a dark joke has to have some basis
in reality I mean Carol saw his wife in
that room earlier if they had never seen
the wife maybe a sick wife down well
joke works I grant that it works most of
the time with nearly all audiences but
not here
to show that for I have sinned it's nice
of sister Charlotte to here out Janice
but only a Catholic priests can take
confession sister Charlotte can not buy
Catholic doctor and minister penance
who's this room upstairs they're not
supposed to go into but you did anyway
you know because otherwise why would you
be telling me about it sister Charlotte
already amazing at regular sins would be
amazing at cinemasins
a sin is a sin no matter the context I
feel like a quarter of this movies
dialogue could be our sizzle reel of
course it's a scary scarecrow on the
premises it's kind of like this house
knows it's in a horror movie don't find
me just hanging out here in the hopes
that you kids play hide and seek and one
of you chooses to hide in here so that I
can scare the shit out of you also just
what is this thing I think I spent most
of the last movie trying to figure out
if it was a ghost or a demon or solid
liquid or gas and I couldn't figure out
what plane of existence this thing lives
in I can see the demon eyes in the horns
but why does it need the doll is the
doll evil or am i evil who's this find
out this fall seriously the conjuring
verse has more spin-offs than a CW show
nobody has time for whatever the hell
this is even if the ghost has this power
why would it do this maybe it just
thinks these two girls suck and wants to
give them a taste of their own medicine
but it doesn't help the scene make any
more sense also are they the only ones
who can hear the ringing assuming it's
making this noise and in the room with
them Kate and Tierney should be able to
hear and see there as well so what's the
plan here demon if Kate doesn't turn on
the light do you keep doing harmless but
creepy things until someone comes in to
witness it's at times like these I feel
like Al Pacino and Glengarry Glen Ross
what's the point what's the point in any
case good thing only Jana's can hear the
record playing and how is that even
possible
Carolyn Nancy just let out a little Yelp
and had everyone in the house checking
on them both of these girls have seen
this devil doll and both times it did
something up in creepy yet neither of
them seems terribly scared of it now I
understand not wanting to look crazy and
but they don't even come up with an
excuse to leave the room why didn't
return at a living B skip through any of
these diary pages it's not as if they
were dated monsters with a sense of
dramatic timing for later discoveries
must be a thing in this universe
[Music]
apparently it's a rule in horror movies
that you have to have the most demonic
looking face when requesting a soul if
any of the demons and ghosts could
represent a calm demeanor and ask nicely
it could go a long way as all I'm saying
also couldn't you have grabbed her soul
without going through this whole
production this is like the expendable
henchmen who yells at the hero before
attacking when the elements
ize is still in play evil takes many
forms it's a doll it's a little girl who
got hit by a truck it's a woman
pretending to be Annabelle's mom it's a
demon in the shadows it's a bunch of
inky blackness on the walls it never
really knows what it wants to be
if the steamin were in college it
changed its major 17 times before
settling on history yes get in the slow
moving stair lift that while outright
unrelated I finished Ivanhoe before this
stair lift got to the bottom yeah you
mean now back to the movie
if Beelzebub could control the lift with
her demonic ways then why did she ever
even let Janice go down the stairs
survives this all so that's it the demon
pulls her up into the air and then
throws her back the whole time I think
so she needs and a cure for polio come
after me so who's so pissed at least it
totally had you and then threw you away
though and in the meantime what's with
all the scary with all the other girls
in the house maybe you won't get adopted
oh yeah I forgot this house is a
makeshift orphanage now and no one's
been around looking to adopt these girls
for this whole movie you know why
because this orphanage is in the middle
of nowhere you won't even be able to
name sure I can't
Janice won Janice two three Linda needs
to work on her doll naming skills and
being less stalkery with her friends is
this also the prequel to single white
female Jesus Christ that's creepy I mean
look at the size of that keyhole also
Linda has proof that this doll just
moves around the house on its own and
sees that it's just hanging out in the
band locked room and she opens the door
anyways Linda deserves whatever hell is
brought up on this seems like a pretty
easy decision to let the popgun go at
this point but horror movie has to
horror all this trouble for the demon to
grab the doll and walk away
was this scene the demon surround with
her toy gun and steals it from the
lights go out and there's a bunch of
footsteps and she sees dirty demon he
tracks and she sees this it's at times
like these when I feel like the band
ministry
she fell asleep I once stayed up all
night paralyzed because I heard snoring
beside me and because I forgot I was
married Linda knew for a fact the demon
was in the goddamn bed under her and she
just dozed off
they can hear Esther's bell ringing from
outside but no one can hear Janice
screaming her head off the other night
right before our accident question since
we just saw Janice get thrown into the
air thrown to the ground and survived
just how is this supposed to make us
feel at this point getting a scary ride
in a wheelchair it's like getting a warm
hug why is the demon ghost or whatever
the this is supposed to be presenting
itself as a nun there was no nun
involved and what happened to be or the
creation of the doll this seems to be an
image more for the viewers benefit than
having anything to do with the story
also seriously she's screaming her head
off I was no one hearing this the other
kids were just there if the demon needs
her body then why is it flinging her
around all over the place oh just like
how demon birds feed their young by the
way why couldn't this have happened
sooner also you didn't hear the outside
Banshee screams but you heard some demon
goo gargling in the barn that's movie
should have been titled Annabelle's
selective hearing that's impossible
that doll was hidden away she must have
go near that doll maybe if you're gonna
have a group of kids living at the house
you'd do a better job of hiding the
demonic doll just a suggestion what's
really gonna bake your noodle is would
Samuel have even seen Annabelle at the
kitchen table if Linda hadn't mentioned
her seems like an odd sentiment mr.
Mullins hasn't been hiding he's been in
this house this entire time
I don't think I'm even scared of this
doll anymore it's clearly not doing
anything except simply being around when
the demon does its thing
[Music]
so are we gonna talk to Sam's wife
before we take him away or no okay no
what is there ready for bed girls I need
to speak to mrs. Maz you're letting
those girls sleep in the house after
that I get that they don't have really
anywhere to go but could they figure
something out better than the house
where dude mysteriously had all his
fingers broken in one hand and then he
died so what did Esther say when she
found out that her husband died did you
guys even do that anybody checking up on
her characters have the best timing when
looking out of windows in horror films
what is with the demonic trickery here
why can't it just take her out instead
of playing this hide-and-seek Bull's
Linda knows the doll is evil but decides
you know what that evil doll what's it
gonna do grab me and try and throw me
into a well I'd like to see that I get
the sister Charlotte would be a little
freaked out now but she hasn't seen any
monster shenanigans yet so wouldn't this
just look like an innocent person
trapped in the well what did she try to
save that person weren't you the one
just seconds ago wanted to run away from
the well because you saw the well
covering about to get knocked off now
you think you've gotten rid of it can't
have a little girl who is both smart
enough to know things like this and have
a limited mental capacity of a mere
child at the same time it's bad I do it
was bad but chose not to let sister
Charlotte in on this so she could have
gotten the girls away starting to look
more and more like the Mullins let these
people come to be demon food she wanted
permission to move into the doll we said
yes and that's when it became stronger
why would the moans have to give a demon
permission to do she if it knew going
into the doll was an option I'm not sure
why it didn't just do it in the Simpsons
one producer apparently gave a note to
the chill runners to make sure that any
time the nuclear power plant was shown
the crow had to call it's funny unuseful
but apparently in horror movies
producers have the same mindset with
running and giggling ghost children this
trope lost its usefulness long ago still
attached to that dog so we locked it
away
where it could be surrounded by the Word
of God since the church was involved
they couldn't figure out a better place
to lock it away than the Mullins home
also torn and pasted pages of the Bible
are really gonna stop this demon this
seems spiritually arbitrary like why
can't you just put a desk in front of
the door with the complete Bible lying
on it now that you've completely sullied
a Bible I'll go in and do my thing
holy water should work Psalm 14:1
describes in detail how to parallax a
demon and as we all know parallax is
good and buried and no one will ever dig
him up make way father if my job is
putting the doll in the closet it was
for all these years okay you can put the
mask back on we're very aware of what
the demon did to you I like to play beer
pong with this eye socket they're on the
way let's get somewhere safe what the
hell did you tell the cops there's a
list out there of shots and horror
movies from the last decade that need to
be retired this needs to be at the top
of that list on the sixth day the
producers of this film added the last
horror cliche they hadn't done yet into
this movie and saw that it was good but
I thought the demon was inside Janice is
this demon multitasking now there's just
some other thing in the conjuring
universe that we're gonna have to worry
about in the future what did the chances
that this farm could contain to
conjuring universe demons at the same
time and beside doesn't Warner Brothers
already have a scarecrow from another
universe you should burn your hands if
you try to screw it in while it's been
on all this time demon who obviously
isn't stopped by doors is acting like
this door is an obstacle all the sudden
that or he's just a dick both work for
sending purposes I feel like half of
this movie as a character observing a
room as if they're watching it only
through a movie camera and their sight
is limited by only what the camera sees
Annabelle - Annabelle heart about sweets
- she looks just like you
it's a times like these when I feel like
aliens stripped from screwed Oh
why would Annabelle be back in the room
where her soul was trapped and the movie
has given no indication that it wouldn't
still be trapped if she was put back in
there sister Charlotte has a doll and
there's a doll still in the closet how
many dolls are in this house anyway
maybe get out of the room where the
random debris is flying right at you
really doesn't seem like this scripture
room was good at holding so I'm not sure
how they don't remain there for 12 years
introduce you to mr. and mrs. Higgins
all right movie as crafty as this little
twist might seem of making the young
Janice the girl who becomes Annabelle
Higgins from the first film it raises a
lot of issues and questions the first
film leads you to believe that Annabelle
was the biological Higgins daughter they
even have family photos of her at a
younger age than Janice also the family
in the first film actually purchases the
Annabelle doll and just happens to live
next door to the Higgins so that's a
scary coincidence even for the conjuring
verse seems like 12 years must be pretty
important to this demon glad the movie
never sheds any light on that giving us
some needed answers also this every 12
years thing makes no sense does the
demon have a small window of time every
12 years to do its thing
because the only reason it stopped the
first time was because it got locked up
in a room surrounded by holy water in
Scripture the second time it stopped was
almost for the same reasons but with
some wrinkles also also movie finally
makes it to the original Annabelle which
if you recall sucked
so basically nothing then it's at times
like these I feel like David Caruso in
session 9 hey so here's another end of
credit sneak preview and I'm gonna ask
Nick Fury's disguised as an unknown man
that it's dedication to your work so you
have no frame of reference here Donny
you're like a child who wanders into the
middle of a movie so how much further is
it father we have clearance Clarence
Roger Roger
what's our vector Victor did you hear
you soul is mine must go faster